bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver à
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne les travaux de la
commission d' enquête sur le coût réel
de l'électricité
cet après midi les sénateurs
auditionnent andré claude lacoste c'est
le président de l'asn l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire
cette autorité avait rendu un rapport
début janvier dans lequel il était
stipulé que les centrales françaises
avaient un niveau de sûreté suffisant
mais qu'il fallait investir des
milliards d'euros pour renforcer leur
robustesse alors ces investissements
vont ils avoir un impact sur le coût de
l'électricité
éléments de réponse avec cette audition
bien mes chers collègues nous allons
démarrer si vous voulez bien monsieur le
président de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
cela dit vous n'aviez pas le choix je
crois qu'on a un peu obligé de répondre
aux invitations des commissions d
enquête parlementaire
mais je vous remercie d'être là
aujourd'hui nous sommes exactement à
mi-chemin de tout aux auditions
alors petit rappel de la raison pour
laquelle vous êtes ici monsieur
président cette commission denquête
était une demande du groupe écologie du
du sénat le bureau a accepté cette
demande et donc elle a été créée le
rapporteur on est monsieur jean
desessard j'en ai été nommé un président
et je vais vous demander de respecter un
petit peu la tradition en la matière
c'est à dire que je vais vous demander
de prêter serment
je vais vous demander de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité et je vais
enfin vous demander de lever la main
droite et de dire je le jure le jure je
vous en remercie alors pour faciliter
votre audition disions pour la rendre
pour entrer plus vivement dans le débat
notre rapporteur jean desessard vous
envoyez à l'avance un certain nombre de
questions de manière à ce que vous
puissiez les préparer il est bien
évident que dans cette mission d'
enquête sur les problèmes du coût de
l'énergie du prix de l'énergie
toute la mission que vous avez rempli
sur l'après fukushima est le résultat de
votre mission
des travaux nécessaires à faire dans
l'eau 59 centrales nucléaires et le
sujet qui nous intéresse de loin le plus
notre rapporteur va vous rappeler ces
questions parce que c'est important
qu'elles figurent au procès verbal et
ensuite vous y répondez à priori dans
l'ordre sauf si ça vous semble pour nous
éclaircir plus intéressant de d'inverser
n'hésitez pas à le faire
monsieur le rapporteur à vous la parole
merci président donc monsieur lacoste
nous avons adressé cinq questions
la première pouvez vous faire un point
sur le chantier de le p r de flamanville
et notamment sur ses conséquences
financières pour la production
d'électricité à partir de paix m
seconde question à quel moment peut-on
évaluer le coût des travaux de sûreté
post fukushima
pouvez-vous commenter cet égard le choix
fait par le gouvernement de surévaluer
de 3 euros le prix de l'arenh estimé par
la commission champsaur
troisième question commenter les
conclusions du rapport de la cour des
comptes de janvier 2012
concernant les charges futures y compris
le mécanisme de couverture d'une partie
de ses charges par des actifs dédiés les
sites prévus
un projet dont le stockage des déchets
vous par est-il suffisant en termes de
dimensions dimensionnement quatrième
question pouvez vous commenter le régime
actuel de responsabilité civile en cas
d'accident nucléaire ainsi que les
dispositions contenues à cet égard dans
le projet de loi numéro 4 181 2011 2012
déposé au sénat le 21 mars 2012
les différents risques liés à
l'exploitation de centrales nucléaires y
compris ceux liés à un accident majeur
peuvent-ils être couvert par un système
de type assurantielle le corps dit pas
créée en 2005 pour définir une gestion
des conséquences d'un accident nucléaire
et tu dit il la question du coût
financier d'un tel accident est
cinquième et dernière question sur le
plan stratégique
comment peut-on concilier la nécessité
de planifier longtemps à l'avance le
remplacement de centrales nucléaires
avec les incertitudes sur la durée de
vie de ses centrales
celle-ci découlant aussi bien du
principe des visites décennales qui peut
conduire
l'asn à interdire la poursuite de
l'exploitation que du manque
d'expérience concrète sur le
vieillissement des centrales nucléaires
au-delà de l'âge de 30 ans en france
voilà monsieur lennon les cinq questions
nous avons adressé reçu la cote monsieur
le président je vous laisse la parole
vous nous laissez quand même un petit
temps de questions réponses à la fin de
votre exposé en réponse à ces cinq
questions je vous en remercie merci
monsieur bélanger du compte pas vous la
base pour dire avec un exposé d'une
heure d'abord sur l'invitation que moi
le fait d'intervenir devant vaud c'est
tout à fait important pour une
institution comme l'autorité sûreté
nucléaire autorités n créative
indépendante de teura porter devant le
parlement et ses différentes
manifestations
autorité indépendante nous ne rapportons
pas dans le gouvernement mais nous
considérons que nous rapportons devant
le parlement
des rapports privilégiés à l'évidence
avec l'office parlementaire des choix
scientifiques et technologiques mais
très régulièrement
nous sommes là mais intervenir il nous
confierons que c'est en même temps un
honneur un devoir et une pratique
normale
sur les différentes questions ce que
vous avez posé je commencerai par dire
que la scène à deux grands types
d'activités nous contrôlons d'une part
la sûreté et la radioprotection sur des
choses que j'appelle des grosses bêtes
150 grosses bêtes dont les réacteurs
d'edf dont les installations de la hague
dont des acteurs recherche et puis la
vampire une autre activité qui n'est pas
dans le champ jourd'hui mais qui est
fondamental pour nous c'est ce que
l'aplomb du caire de proximité nous
contrôlons l'utilisation des sources
radioactives dans beaucoup de domaines
inscrits recherche et surtout médecine
est actuellement l objet principaux et
la radioprotection des patients sujets
qui a été initiée par accident qui sont
survenus à epinal et sujet de long terme
qui est la croissance des doses reçues
par les patients en matière de
radiographie je dis simplement un mot
suffit pour dire que la surveillance des
grosses bêtes n'est qu'un de nos deux
axes de travail
alors j'en viens maintenant aux cinq
questions que vous avez posé en
commençant par le père et en suivant les
questions dans l'ordre où il avait
dénoncé le p r est le premier réacteur
de puissance construit en france depuis
longtemps n'a pas été construit un code
puissance en france depuis les recteurs
de choses et de civaux ça veut dire
qu'il ya une interruption de
construction pendant pratiquement une
vingtaine d'années alors nous contrôlons
de près la construction du réacteur p r
nous avons commencé à contrôler cette
construction dirait avant même que le
chantier débuté il faut se souvenir que
la conception du réacteur père au début
des années 90 est le résultat d'une
prise de position d'autorité sûreté
nucléaire à l'époque mon prédécesseur en
91 a écrit à edf au cea et à framatome
qu' il n'était plus question compris en
france des réacteurs du type n 4 qu'il
fallait passer aux générations futures
tirant les conséquences de tchernobyl et
c'est cette prise de position de l'asn
qui entraînait l'étude des options
sûreté
d'un réacteur plus sûr soit acteur
d'abord été franco français il a ensuite
été franco allemand c'est à dire que
pendant les années qui ont suivi 90
l'ensemble des acteurs français et
allemands on travaille ensemble
je me souviens en particulier de prises
de position unique que d'emprise mon
collègue allemand et moi en anglais sur
les principaux passages de sûreté de
l'état opère
nous connaissions un père depuis
longtemps
c'est le résultat d'un certain nombre
d'imposition que nous avons fait à
l'époque alors j'en viens la
construction nous surveillons de près la
construction depuis le début la
construction nous avons opéré plus d'une
centaine d'inspection sur le chantier et
nous avons opéré une cinquantaine
d'inspection l'ex dans les services
centraux d'edf
chez les fournisseurs chez sous
traitants donc nous suivrons de très
près cette construction à quoi nous nous
attendions nous depuis le départ
l'attendions à ce que hier sur les
difficultés nées de la nécessité de re
apprendre ce que c'est que la
construction des réacteurs de puissance
je me souviens d'avoir été invité à
participer à une réunion organisée par
nos homologues américains les
commissaires de la nuclear regulatory
commission
quelques années nos homologues avaient
réuni les chefs d' autorité sûreté de
france de finlande au japon et de taïwan
et j'avais été mais alors dit il pose la
question si on recommence à compteur
d'acteurs de puissance aux états unis
quels conseils vous nous donner pour se
payer il aurait dit le problème est
celui du rpt learning
comment réapprendre à construire comment
apprendre à surveiller la construction
d'un réacteur
nous avons et le nous c'est pas
seulement l'autorité de sûreté c'est edf
et ses sous-traitants
oubliez ce que nous chacun dans notre
domaine avions l'habitude de faire et
donc ce qu'on retrouve c'est exactement
ceci quand oui à des difficultés à
mettre correctement en oeuvre le béton
bas c'est clairement un manque
d'habitude la qualité nucléaire quand
nous arrêtons la construction de tel ou
tel élément d'un pressuriseur
fabriquée en italie par une filiale de
groupe pour le compte d'areva s'est
clairement que ce sous traitant ne s'est
pas mis en mesure de respecter les
normes de qualité et les normes de
sûreté du nucléaire est tout à fait
évident que l'épisode le plus récent qui
va intervenir en et puis l'autre
touchant pont polaire est un épisode de
manque de qualité tout à fait flagrant
autrement dit on se trouve face à un
manque d'habitude de la construction
alors ça se traduit parfois par des
choses qui se rattrape facilement ce
sera ça se traduit parfois par des
choses qui impose d'autre part un arrêt
du chantier on a déjà été par deux fois
deux chantiers pour des motifs de
bétonnage ça se traduit par les retards
quand c'est edf lui-même qui constatent
les défauts mais c'est clairement un
processus de ré apprentissage qui n'est
pas étonnant mais qui est très frappant
quand on regarde alors chacun peut
nourrir l'espoir que c'est un processus
de l'apprentissage ci pourrait servir si
de nouveaux réacteurs au pays a été
construit en france ou non mais il est
clair que c'est un processus extrêmement
prégnante extrêmement important voilà
sur ce produit quoi je n'en tire la
guitare et par des questions si vous le
permettez
le deuxième point c'est celui du montant
des travaux de sûreté post fukushima
alors clairement post fukushima est un
évènement majeur comme tchernobyl comme
free malendure à un post fukushima
comme il ya eu un post it après
fukushima même chose que pour tia mobile
et three mile island et a clairement
beaucoup de choses à en retirer
avec une difficulté si classique sur ce
genre d'événement majeur c'est que la
compréhension complète du phénomène peut
prendre très longtemps j'ai souvenir que
après three mile island il avait fallu
six ans pour être sûr que le coeur du
réacteur avait fondu et dans
l'intervalle des papiers scientifiques
avaient dit que le coeur du réacteur
n'avait pas affronté le sentiment qu
exprime une autorité sûreté nucléaire
c'est qu'ils peuvent valoir jusqu'à dix
ans pourra totalement sûr d'avoir
compris fukushima et ça nous met donc
d'une situation où
à l'évidence il faut tirer surtout me
conséquence fukushima celle qui nous
paraissent les plus évidentes il n'est
pas exclu que au fil du temps au fil de
la compréhension du film phénomène nous
soyons amenés à revenir en arrière et à
dire telle ou telle prescription de la
reprise n'était pas fondée c'est très
inconfortable sur le plan intellectuel
ça peut être très coûteux mais je pense
qu'il faut être clair c'est quelque
chose qui fait partie du paysage
or toujours est il qu'il est apparu
rapidement qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de conséquences à tirer de
fukushima et ses conséquences ont
compris deux formes les stress tests au
niveau européen et l'élévation
complémentaires sur tel ou français le
conseil européen des 24 et 25 mars 2011
a décidé de lancer de stress tests et le
premier ministre françois fillon ne vous
l'avez écrit quelques jours avant pour
demander le lancer des évaluations
complémentaires de sûreté alors un club
de chefs d'autorité qui appelle weiner
avait anticipé de l'avion commencé à
rédiger un cahier des charges et
décharges été approuvé et le processus
pré spes évaluations complémentaires de
sûreté a été lancé au niveau européen
était il a été lancé sur l'essonne
réacteurs de puissance au niveau
français l'ont décidé de l'étendre au
niveau français évasion complémentaires
sûreté ont porté à la fois sur les
acteurs puissance et sur l'ensemble des
installations concernées par fukushima
se mirent en particulier l'installation
comportant des piscines avec du
combustible usé donc je vais porter les
évaluations dans un premier temps non
pas sur les 59 réacteurs de puissance
mais sur 80 installations
quand j 50 attractions surpuissance à
dire fait porter les évasions complément
sûreté aussi bien que 58 réacteurs en
fonctionnement que sur le recteur de
paix à flamanville et puis deuxième
extension qu'une amende et sites en
france c'est de donner un poids
particulier à tout ce qui est facteur
socio humain et relationnel
nous avons fait parce que ça nous
paraissait tout à fait fondés et nous
l'avons fait à la demande d'un certain
nombre de parties prenantes ont très
clairement les syndicats n'ont pas
encore traité ce sujet facteurs
monsieur humain exceptionnel mais il est
clair qu'à nos yeux que c'est un point
tout à fait important alors nous avons
lancé le processus en france en
demandant à rapport aux exploitants en
réponse un cahier des charges dont j'ai
dit qu'il avait été élaboré au niveau
européen rapporte exploitants a été
fourni en septembre non finalisées par
notre expert technique lire et c'est
nous l'avons fait analyser par nouveau
permanent d'experts et avec une très
large ouverture expertise la réunion des
groupes permanents a réuni plus de 200
personnes pendant trois jours et nous
avons demandé l'avis d'experts français
et étrangers la vie dans cette
association environnementale très large
participation
ça nous a conduit à une prise de
position que nous avons rendu public le
3 janvier le 3 janvier j'ai remis mon
rapport au premier ministre à 11 heures
et nous l'avons tenu une conférence de
presse en début d'après-midi alors que
résiste-t-il de cette prise de position
de l'asn
il résulte un certain nombre de prises
de position ils sont des prises de
position de principe que nous la tâche
ont maintenant à traduire en décisions
juridiquement opposable au principal
pour les réacteurs de puissance trois
choses un noyau dur
un concept qui a été proposé par edf
mise en forme par l'irsn et qui consiste
par dire que dans une installation de
verre et en partie d'une centrale il ya
une partie qui doit encore mieux résisté
que le reste aux agressions externes sa
ville en particulier un centre de
gestion de crise bunkérisé et un diesel
d'ultime secours bunkérisé et en
particulier deuxième sujet la force
d'action ou d'intervention rapide
proposés par edf
ça nous paraît une bonne idée dire la
capacité de projeter sur un site ou un
accident grave interviendrait se
projeter en même temps des personnes
compétentes et du matériel
supplémentaire public troisième point
des études de faisabilité de dispositifs
supplémentaires de protection de l'eau
souterraine en cas d'accident grave
c'est un sujet plus délicat
techniquement mais que nous paraît
s'imposer
alors ça c'est ce que nous avons indiqué
être toute prise de position c'est ce
que nous traduisons
nous allons traduire en conte décision
nous avons préparé des projets décision
la doite transparence et sécurité en
matière nucléaire l'impôt de conduite
edf
on a consulté d'être certain d'ailleurs
que nous avions nous le collège de l'asn
une audition d'edf sur ces sujets sera
lent prendre une décision d'ici d'ici le
mois de juin alors par définition les
décisions précises ne sont pas encore
prêts
nous attendons les acclamations de f et
puis nous prendrons toute autre position
sur les coûts résultant de ceux ci nous
disposons d'une évaluation sommaire qui
a été avancé par edf et qui consiste à
dire que le coût de l'ensemble des
mesures que nous imposerons sans doute
vous voyez encore une fois décisions ne
sont pas prises
le détail n'est pas connue c'est donc
une évolution très sommaire est de
l'ordre de 10 milliards d'euros
n'avons pas d'élément permettant de
mettre en doute les sommes qui nous
paraît directement sommes-nous assez
vraisemblable compte tenu de ce qu'on
croit savoir les différents éléments
cause voilà sur ce point le troisième
l'a 30 question qui nous est posée
concerne les conclusions du rapport la
cour des comptes rendu public en janvier
sur ce point là je vois d'abord commencé
par dire que nous avons travaillé très
étroite en liaison avec la cour des
comptes
nous avons été auditionnés par la cour
des comptes nous avons fourni à son
élément nous avons répondu à son projet
d'observation et et nous y avons répondu
d'autant plus volontiers que l'avion le
sentiment de la cour des comptes faisait
un travail de fond qui était depuis
longtemps nécessaire parce que nous nous
trouvons effectivement en france face à
un certain nombre de charges et de coûts
importants qu'il s'agisse du
démantèlement qu'il s'agisse de gestion
du déchet il s'agit du provisionnement
qui à nos yeux n'ont fait l'objet
d'études que relativement imparfaite ou
ou incertaines ou une grossière et les
bons sentiments que sur le sujet la cour
des comptes a porté sa capacité
d'investigation et son expertise et donc
je dirais que nous partageons très
largement l'ensemble des conclusions de
la cour des comptes
l'une est concluant importante c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de koumassi t mais il
est conclu importante c'est que c'est un
ensemble de coûts dont il faudrait
sûrement préciser le montant
un des points et en particulier le coût
du futur stockage de bure s'il est
autorisé qui est clairement la dépense
la plus massive dans le champ mais il
faut également préciser le coût du
démantèlement
bien sûr le show de ce genre cosider il
ya très sûrement matière investigations
j'ajoute que un des points qui nous
paraissent les plus importants et celui
de la couverture financière des charges
futures
c'est un point que l'avion déjà relevé
je vais qu'elle nous étions déjà
manifestés et sur lequel la cour a ainsi
cité la loi du 28 juin 2006 gestion
déchets est tout à fait clair et demande
que les provisions pour l'ensemble des
charges d'avenir soit gagée par les
actifs qui soit suffisamment sûre et
suffisamment liquide et nous voyons
comme quelque chose d'anormal comme une
façon de tourner la loi le fait que très
régulièrement le gouvernement s'attache
à contourner les dispositions de cette
loi en permettant que parmi les gages de
ses provisions figure vendez les actions
de filiales où figurent même des
engagements de l'état dont on sait
malheureusement parfois ce qu'ils valent
encore une fois la loi disait tout à
fait clairement il faut des actifs
devrait d'actifs mobilisables et sur le
quatrième point que vous avez soulevés
concernant les l'accident nucléaire
alors là je commence par une affirmation
qui est une information constante de la
scène depuis qu'il a été créé c'est que
personne ne peut garantir qu'il n'y aura
jamais d'accident nucléaire en france
on peut le dire sous une deuxième forme
on peut le dire que un accident en
france ne peut jamais être exclue on
peut dire qu une troisième forme
l'improbable est possible mais que de
toute façon ça conduit au fait que
personne
ne peut garantir qu'il n'y aura jamais
d'accident nucléaire en france
à plus forte raison personne ne peut-il
garantir qu'il n'y aura jamais
d'accident nucléaire en europe
donc c'est quelque chose dont il faut
tenir compte alors nous de notre côté là
ont tenu compte de deux façons
premièrement en multipliant l'exercice
de sûreté nucléaire long menant 10 à 12
par an mais s'ils ont mobilisé autant
que possible l'ensemble des parties
prenantes en y associant quand c'est
possible des exercices d'évacuation même
portée limitée et puis une deuxième
façon pour nous de manifester souci a
été de réfléchir autre post accidentelle
nous avons demandé au premier ministre
en 2005 à aix-les-bains fière de nous
confier une mission de réflexion ne veut
pas sa clientèle dire la gestion de tout
ce qui suit un accident c'est à dire les
gestions elle des populations
éventuellement évacuer la gestion du
territoire la gestion des récoltes la
gestion du bâti la gestion de l'eau
c'est une infection extrêmement
difficile à ma connaissance nous
la france est le seul pays où cette
réflexion est menée avec ton extrêmement
difficile nous allons donc tenu deux
colloques internationaux donc
prochainement publier un rapport
proposant des mesures au gouvernement
mais le fait que nous ayons lancé cette
étude se sont parfaitement publiques
trop 400 personnes y participent montre
bien que pour nous la possibilité d'un
accident nucléaire est tout à fait
présentes dans le champ
voilà ce que je souhaitais dire et
initialement alors deuxième point c'est
le coût d'un accident nucléaire je crois
qu'il faut vraiment se faire une idée de
ce que c'est que de coups possibles
l'accident nucléaire
dia quelques estimations préliminaires
de l'irsn qui montrait que pour un
accident modérer le coût moyen pouvait
être de 70 milliards d'euros et le coût
estimé l'accident de fukushima ou de
tchernobyl
ce n'est pas du tout du tout facile
compte tenu du fait qu'il s'agit de
chiffres et des dommages causés à des
populations avec mort ou 100 morts à
combien chiffrez vous le fait d'avoir
évacué un territoire d'avril que des
personnes mais l'ordre de grandeur est
probablement de 600 milliards à 1000
milliards d'euros
alors de façon en confirmant ses
estimations nous avons essayé de passer
commande une étude à ce sujet en
novembre dernier
personne n'a soumissionné pour faire
cette étude
ça veut pas renvoyer à quelque chose
fait état de quelque chose d'important
dire que sur un terrain de sujets il n'y
a pas de terreau de compétences ou de
laboratoires ou 200 ans d'études
nécessaires pour se lancer dans les
études nécessaires
toutefois il assène a commencé à le
faire mais il croit qu'il est tout à
fait important que que des études soient
développées si possible d'ailleurs
l'étude contradictoire et indépendante
pour qu est le début d'un débat qu'est
ce que c'est que le coût d'un accident
nucléaire
la responsabilité de pierre service
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est issu est
il possible d'imaginer le couvert sa
part l'assurance est ce que ça a un sens
facilement tant de ce genre avec
jean-christophe ne l'étions il ya des
jouets à washington ils ont participé à
un séminaire à l'université george
washington et j'ai été très frappée de
voir qu'un économiste fondamentalement
libéral finissait sa présentation fut
d'accident nucléaire en dix ans il ya un
niveau de risque d'accident nucléaire ou
seul l'état c'est assez fort et puissant
peut il finit ce se mettre en face du
risque et on voit bien que ces récents
comme fukushima survenue en slovénie
mallett a sauvé n'y résisterait pas
alors par rapport à ça c'est le problème
des montants plafonds de responsabilité
nucléaire c'est vilain qui figure la
question est est un problème qui est
important mais ce n'est pas le problème
majeur est tout à fait clair que nous
considérons comme une bonne chose que le
gouvernement a déposé un projet de loi
au sénat qui tend à porter le plafond de
la responsabilité il passe en clair de
91,5 millions d'euros à 700 millions
d'euros
mais voyez que ça ne couvre qu'une
partie du champ ça couvre la partie
basse du chant et encore une fois on
conclut lyon mais c'est un peu la même
conclusion serait que celle que j'avais
sur les sujets démantèlement
je pense que tout à fait matière à un
certain nombre d'études
d'abord sans doute peu cohérente et qui
peu à peu par des bap peuvent converger
et puis la question que vous posez et sl
la planification de la durée de
fonctionnement des centrales et la
politique énergétique leur prêtera mots
de vocabulaire mais qui n'est pas
innocent nous abstenons de parler de
durée de vie des centrales
nous parlons durée de fonctionnement que
pour nous à durée de vie c'est
l'ensemble durée de construction culture
et de fonctionnement plus dur est
démantèlement donc nous parlons de deux
durée de fonctionnement
alors quelle est la règle en france
quand une autorisation est donnée
l'autorisation est donnée sans
limitation dans le temps des mutations
explicite dans le temps
l'autorisation est donnée tant que
l'installation peut être considéré comme
sûr
et le fait que l'installation est sûrs
et vérifiés j'irai au jour le jour par
simple inspection que nous pratiquons
nous pratiquons une inspection par an
sur les socios d'installations
nucléaires mais il part en surnom sur
l'ensemble dont plus de la moitié sur
edf
oui que 3 55 cents sur edf
donc nous pratiquons d'inspection au
jour le jour nous réjouissons quand il
ya un incident un accident nous faisons
du retour d'expérience qu'on apprend
quelque chose d'étrange et ça je dirais
c'est au jour le jour
puis il rendez vous plus solennelle sous
forme de réexamen de sûreté périodique
tous les dix ans on appelle souvent sa
visite décennale
selon dire tout et dix ans nous
vérifions deux choses nous vérifions si
l'installation est conforme son
référentiel dont est ce que
l'information et conformerai qui
s'applique à elle donc nous vérifions si
tel ou tel composant a vieilli nous
vérifions s'il ya pas tel ou tel défaut
qui apparaît dans le béton nous
vérifions si la vérification de
conformité et puis nous faisons par
ailleurs une révélation de sûreté en
huit ans ben voilà un station telle
qu'elle est comment se compare-t-elle à
des installations plus récentes et plus
sûrs et donc tout demandant à
l'exploitant d'essayer de faire
progresser la sûreté en exploitation au
regard
de référence plus récentes je prends
avec l'amp type xv est un acteur 900
mégawatts
tous les dix ans nous demandons qu
est-ce qui parmi les objectifs sûreté du
réacteur au père peut être appliquée
raisonnablement à ce réacteur
louis et d'objectifs conformité et
réévaluations sûreté ça veut donc dire
c'est que nous pouvons être amenés à
prendre la décision de fermer acteurs
aussi bien tous les dix ans de façon un
peu solennel ou en disant vous disant
vraiment nous ne voyons pas continue
depuis cinq ans mais nous pouvons
prendre au jour le jour est une des
caractéristiques du parc français c'est
qu'il est extrêmement sans tarder il est
alors l'avantagé d'un parc standardisé
et claire une adoriez il est économique
saas et concernent essentiellement edf
et puis deuxièmement chaque fois qu'on
trouve quelque chose à améliorer chaque
fois que la dure tout explose à faire on
peut l'appliquer ensemble des réacteurs
et donc améliorer sûreté du parc
la contrepartie c'est qu'on peut se
trouver un jour face à un accident ou un
pépin ou un défaut grave affectant
l'ensemble du parc et à son alarme la
nation se trouve dans un état difficile
que je caractériserais par quelque chose
qui illustre bien le propos le président
de l'autorité sûreté nucléaire allant
voir suivant suivant l'air du temps
présent république ou le premier
ministre et lui disant tu es là il ya un
choix que je ne peux pas faire
il s'agit de savoir si on coupe
l'électricité ou si on accepte que les
réacteurs fonctionnent en est à sûreté
de gratter quand nous faisons tout pour
éviter qu'il en soit ainsi
chaque fois qu'on trouve un défaut nous
demandons c'est générique on essaie de
prévenir mais ça veut donc dire c'est
que il y a la possibilité que les
installations soient traités de façon
unitaire ou collectives à tout moment et
en particulier à l'occasion des
dérèglements décennaux tout ceci n'a de
sens que si on peut faire fonctionner la
mécanique comme je viens de dire dire
que si il ya une politique énergétique
suffisante pour permettre effectivement
d'éviter un conflit entre sûreté
nucléaire et sécurité énergétique et
notre souci
et bien celui là nous avons par moment
le sentiment que faute d'investir dans
de nouvelles capacités de production et
peu nous importe qu'elle soit nucléaire
ou autre faute d' investir de nouvelles
capacités de production
la france risque de se trouver une
situation où il peut y avoir un conflit
entre le maintien en fonctionnement
d'une partie du parc nucléaire et
l'approvisionnement l'approvisionnement
français lors nous ne disons que nous
craignons qu'un complice le genre arrive
c'est la cour des comptes va plus loin
elle dit que d'ores et déjà il ya une
décision implicite de prolongation de la
durée de fonctionnement du parc
nucléaire faute de capacité alternative
mais c'est clairement pour nous un
soutien important et et voyez bien que
le point pour nous c'est que le
rendez-vous des dix ans est solennel
eloi d'épuiser le nombre d occasions où
nous pouvons être amenés à dire cette
telle ou telle centrale à vocation
affirmée
voilà monsieur le président de façon
sommaire un premier round de réponses à
vos questions ce même à préciser
monsieur le président je remercie moi
j'ai quatre questions très précises et
cote à vous demander mais avant je
voudrais demander aux rapporteurs s'il a
eu réponse à ces questions aussi il a
besoin d'un complément de précisions les
deux présidents monsieur la colle ça mon
tour je vous remercie pour la précision
et même la franchise de vos réponses et
vous avez marqué et moi ce qui me
retient donc c'est vous avez répondu est
assez précisément question mais vous
avez mis le dos vous avez vous parlé de
d'être à certains moments inconfortable
intellectuellement
alors je retiens ce mot dans le sens que
j'imagine pour plus de trois exemples
enfin pas trois exemples les trois
précisions que je demande le matériel
pour inspecter le les endroits sensibles
où on ne peut pas accéder
j'ai vu d'un petit film effectivement
vos inspecteurs je crois aller à
brennilis et regarder les sacs qui a été
chargée pour les déchets demandé à ce
qu'ils soient refaits donc ça allait
trouver ça très bien mais vous pouvez
pas voir la même démarche que vous allez
dans la la cuve donc qui est garant du
matériel que vous mettez du contrôle
est-ce que c'est fait par edf donc à ce
moment là qu elle ait des raisons la
marge d'autonomie que vous avez pour un
contrôle technique dans les endroits
inaccessibles redire j'avais ces besoins
de ces questions la deuxième question là
ce que vous dites
après fukushima nous avons des des
choses nouvelles avoir été compris vous
dit on mais il nous faut au moins des
fois cinq ou six années pour bien
comprendre mais est-ce que ça fait pas
drôle pour l'utiliser mais est-ce que ça
pose pas beaucoup de questions de voir
que des choses que vous croyez avoir
résolu en tant qu autorité de sûreté
bien se montre que dans ce qui se passe
c'est des choses imprévisibles qui alors
est-ce que qu'elle fasse je sais pas
quel est le la méthode que vous avez par
rapport à des choses nouvelles qui
arrivent que ne vieillit pas prévu et
par rapport à l'avenir de drs que cela
peut se faire comment qu'en est il et je
relis ça votre dernière interrogation et
je vous en remercie de l'avoir posée
aussi franchement vous avez dire au bout
d'un moment s'il n'y a pas
la être sûr que au niveau énergétique on
est suffisamment la sécurité énergétique
vous avez employé sont là et bien on ne
sera plus ou moins poussé on va dire ou
inciter ou à dire que ma foi c'est il
faut quand même continuer l'exploitation
alors si je vous remercie de cette
franchise parce que souvent quand on
demande aux gens mais faut-il poursuivre
la durée de vie de fonctionnement enfin
la durée de fonctionnement et nous
disent veille à l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire et vous aujourd'hui vous dites
oui mais nous aussi on peut être soumis
non pas que technique pas s'il ya
vraiment quelque chose qui va pas mais
vous dites vous pouvez de soumis à un
choix qu'il devrait normalement part
élevée de votre fonction et que vous
êtes amené à choisir parfois entre la
sécurité énergétique et une haute
sécurité nucléaire fage et j'ai cru
comprendre ça donc c'était pour définir
un petit peu mieux cette notion d'un
confortable intellectuellement dans
lequel vous situez merci monsieur
rapporterait pas mal de questions je
crois monsieur le président merci
monsieur pédant d'abord sur la première
question c'est comment vérifier ton
l'état du matériel ou l'état
d'interaction et asa centrale dans des
endroits sensibles alors il ya un
premier point sur lequel il faut être
clair c'est un principe fondamental de
la sûreté nucléaire
il est exprimé dans l'est dans les
certificats mental de naira il est
exprimé dans la loi tsn le premier
responsable assure tessa centre de la
centrale c'est edf et si l'exploitant
est considérée globalement comme non
fiable c'est extrêmement clair on doit
lui retirer sa licence d'exploitation
c'est tout à fait clair donc je dirais
est tout à fait normal que au premier
degré ce soit edf qui est à charge de
vérifier l'état c'est l'installation des
riffs y étale son matériel de faire
l'ensemble des mesures nous nous lavons
des moyens de vérification la voie des
moyens de vérification avec l'assistance
technique de l'irsn nous pouvons faire
appel à des tierces parties
je prends un exemple le bétonnage
de flamanville 3 nous nous sommes pas
directement expérience des tonnages il
ya les ré scène des gens compétents
auquel on a fait appel
donc nous ne sommes pas dépourvus je
prends un autre exemple quand il s'agit
de prendre parti sur la capacité de la
cuve des réacteurs aller au delà de 30
ans il ya un débat sur un certain nombre
d'éléments salue le débat ait été est
nourri par rapport d'une nos divisions
spécialisées qui a des visions et
équipements sous pression
c'est analyser par un groupe d'experts
dans lesquelles il ya des experts
français et étrangers et que nous
fournir tous les maux donc je ne sens
pas dépourvu du point de vue technique
mais encore une fois ceux-ci ne marche
que si nous sommes là bien considéré
c'est le cas qu'en face de nous nous
avons des exploitants qui sont dignes
d'une certaine confiance passant du mini
certaine confiance
et encore une fois si cette concertée
confiance pas il ne reste qu'une
solution c'est on enlève la liste des
côtés deuxième question vous poser c'est
également une question de fond met-il
pas drôle je prends votre adjectif de
constater que nous sommes amenés à
regarder ensemble d'éléments nouveaux
après fukushima premiers éléments ce je
crois que quand il survient quelque
chose comme fukushima
il faut pas avoir de la fecq d'orgueil
consistant à dire je refuse la regarde
de regarder les chaudes où je refuse de
reconnaître qu'il ya des éléments
nouveaux
quoi l'orgueil est extrêmement mauvais
conseiller sur ce genre de sujet le
balte et vous une anecdote qui est
survenu récemment un incident que je
considère comme grave en corée du sud
donc l'incident considéré comme d'hab en
corée du sud étaient masquées par
l'opérateur pour un motif qui sembla
autant qu'on le sache être celui
l'honneur national
c'est intéressant de voir quoi je peux
conduire d'un concept des villes donc
faut que le chemin est intervenue nous
ne sommes pas sûrs d'avoir tout compris
nous prenons les mesures que nous
paraissait plus immédiate sans s'en fout
d'orgueil alors je prends exemple sur un
nombre de gens de l'andi le tsunami
faille à trois sujets qui sont étudiées
via des évaluations complémentaires de
sûreté
les agressions naturelles tsunami
tremblement de terre
inondations et cetera deuxième sujet
perte d'alimentation électrique perte de
refroidissement et troisième sujet
gestion de fait je vous en dis les
tsunamis c'est pas crédible en europe
réponse dans un pays comme la france
l'équivalent tsunami c'est l'hypothèse
la rupture d'un certain nombre de
barrages consécutif sur des cours d'eau
nous regardons ça qu'à présent à
contenir et c'était tellement improbable
qu'on ne le prenait pas en compte sans
fausse honte
nous lisons il faut le prendre en compte
et ainsi de suite mais encore une fois
pas de réaction de faux d'orgueil
il ya des choses à apprendre de
fukushima au moins dans la version
actuelle je continue il peut nous
survenir des choses désagréables sur le
plan intellectuel pour le mans la
lecture fukushima c'est c'est le tsunami
qui a été plus dévastateur le
tremblement de terre ne va pas être
tellement été au fil du temps on peut
apprendre qu'il n'était pas si bien qu
une fois à nous de tirer le retour
d'expérience aussi aussi profondément
qu'il est possible mais encore une fois
sans enfant sans son pouce pudeur sans
fausse honte et c'est la même chose que
font nos collègues étrangers alors le
troisième point ce que vous avez fait
c'est la sécurité énergétique c'est tout
à fait clair que pour nous le sujet que
j'ai abordé que vous avez au prix est un
sujet fondamental
il ya certainement un point sur lequel
je corrige après ce que vous avez dit si
un jour il y avait un conflit patent
entre le maintien en fonctionnement de
réacteurs qui ne seraient pas
suffisamment sur nos lieux et
l'approvisionnement écrit si la france
est tout à fait clair que c'est pas
l'autorité sûreté qui prendrait parti
c'est trop trop trop capital soit c'est
pas à nous de prendre l'ensemble des
décisions pour le bonheur du monde
je pense que nous apporterions bonne foi
premier ministre présent un public et
mon sentiment c'est qu'il est
typiquement un sujet sur lequel c'est
soit plus haut niveau de l'exécutif
chaux au parlement de prendre parti mais
à l'évidence mais il ya des limites à
des responsabilités que que ne pouvant
que nous pouvons prendre la cible de ce
président j'ai quelques questions
ensuite madame rossignol monsieur dantec
madame chercher peut-être d'autres
ensuite
les jean-claude très bien mais je les
plains excuse-moi jean-claude je n'avais
pas vu première question concernant je
vous ai bien entendu sur le ce que vous
avez dit à propos de vos contrôles pas
des cndc nommé vos contrôles inopinés il
y a régulièrement des incidents sur nos
centrales
comment est ce que l'asn intervient
parce que les incidents sont graduée de
1 à 7 3 1 c'est tout petit incident est
ce que même lors des incidents
un systématiquement dsm va sur place
soit physiquement soit plus tard
deuxième question vous avez à propos des
provisions vous avez dit les fêtes que
edf est gagé ses provisions sur des
actions rte
ça ne sont pas des vrais actifs je veux
bien que vous précisiez votre pensée
c'est un jugement que vous portez là
dessus pourquoi pourquoi avez-vous
troisième question
j'ai passé une partie de votre question
vous avez dit que le fait que gdf pour
ses provisions est gagé des actions de
rte
ça n'était pas des vrais actifs kg donc
j'aimerais que vous nous préciser un
petit peu votre pensée derrière cela
troisième question concernant votre
mission que vous avez fait rapidement
auprès des 19 rapidement pendant
efficacement vous avez rapidement rempli
notre mission
des travaux nécessaires de travaux de
sûreté nécessaire post-fukushima
vous estimez 18 milliards j'ai beaucoup
aimé votre un été en disant estimation
sommaire et notamment vous avez dit pour
deux raisons il n'est pas impossible que
ça bouge mais à mon avis ça peut bouger
qu'à la hausse en fonction des réponses
que vous donnera l'exploitant sur
l'ensemble des oeuvres vos observations
ça risque d'augmenter un petit peu et
puis seconde augmentation qui ne sera
pas immédiate mais qui risque de
s'étendre dans le temps c'est ce que
j'appelle le retour d'expérience vous
avez bien dit que fukushima va
probablement encore bout
j enfin nous tirons des leçons de ce qui
s'est passé là-bas pendant non pas six
ans comme un three mile island n'est
peut-être plus souvent là j'aimerais
bien un tout petit peu avoir votre
sentiment c'est impossible d'avoir une
estimation mais ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que l'addition risque
d'augmenter au fur et à mesure qu'on en
tirera des leçons
dernière question l'europe c'est un
j'aimerais un avis de l'autorité que
vous représentez pas
et pour lequel j'ai beaucoup de respect
l'europe à un moment a voulu que ce soit
un leurre niveau qui est le contrôle
post fukushima la france le gouvernement
français est pas le seul a réagi assez
vivement disant écoutez nous savons
prendre nos responsabilités nous avons
une autorité de sûreté en qu'elle nous
avons tout à fait confiance et que nous
considérons comme compétente c'est nous
qui allons faire cette évaluation il
malgré tout j'aimerais avoir votre avis
le entre guillemets avantages
inconvénients parce que je partage
l'avis du gouvernement sur vos
compétences et l'autorité et la manière
indépendante dont vous l'assuré mais
peut-être que ça aurait été utile qui
est un contrôle
peut-être un peu plus européen je pense
pas tellement la france 2 dans certains
pays où l'autorité de sûreté mais un
niveau moyen ni vos compétences
merci monsieur le président je reprends
dans l'ordre les quatre questions que
vous avez posé sur la première les
incidents qui surviennent sur les
centrales alors nous il son côté suivant
une échelle qui va qui va en fait de 0 à
8 alors pour nous il importe de l'est de
les classer ou de les côtés rapidement
nous utilisons l'échelle ines est une
chaîne de communication
c'est pas une échelle technique donc
pour nous il est hors de question
d'attendre trois mois pour classés ex
post en place aussi vite que possible à
un mot là aussi pour regarder ce qui
s'est passé à fukushima c'est les
japonais ont systématiquement classés
l'importance de l'événement avec retard
en commençant niveau iv on reconnaît
aussi que dans les moments passés à un
niveau 7 qu'il est pas justifiée nous
d'emblée dans la communication d'un
essai nous l'avons dit deux ou trois
joueurs produit l'accident
si c'était survenu en france nous
considérerions que c'est plus important
que frima raison de moins importants
tchernobyl et d'ambert on a dit vous de
ça sur yon niveau 6 est une fois vous
prenez une décision de ce genre vous
êtes beaucoup plus à l'aise pour
communiquer parce que d'anglais vous
avez reconnu que c'est quelque chose qui
est majeure bon c'est simplement une
incidente donc nous veillons à ce que
les exploitants nous nous propose un
classement nous vérifions ce qu'il en
est c'est nous qui in fine et arrêtons
classement le chaque année en france il
y à peu près 140 incidents de niveau 1
l'installation nucléaire quelques-uns
souhait transports sont sans appel à 145
stationnaire
alors chacun des incidents de niveau 1
fait effectivement l'objet d'inspections
notre pas sur les mines inspection à peu
près que j'évoquais il y en a à peu près
20 à 25% qui sont inopinées ou on va
regarder ce qui se passe sans prévenir
d'autres sont thématiques
certaines sont très actives c'est à dire
après un accident
d'autres une inspection de revue dire
qu'on lâche une nuée d'inspecteurs sur
un site pour regarder les choses sans
encombre dans toute une gamme mais en
particulier d'instruction réactive après
après un incident je doute que ces
sujets en inspection qui ne mène parfois
à reclasser après coup
un incident en dix ans fondamentalement
il est plus grave qui n'avait été vu
initialement
voilà ces incidents j'ajoute que nous
avons une façon d'utiliser placement de
l'échelle ines qui est considérée à
l'étranger comme ruud nos yeux s'est
fondée mais si rude sur les provisions
jeu choqué sur un certain nombre
d'épisodes récent ces deux choses d'une
part le fait que quand le gouvernement
buté sur le fait qu'il fallait des
provisions correspondant aux eaux à
l'esprit de la loi
donc prenez un décret permettant à mes
yeux tourner un peu esprit la loi c'est
typiquement le cas d d d d actions de
rte
et puis par ailleurs il ya des choses
qui me paraissent rigoureusement
contraire la loi ce mec je prends une
partie des provisions pour démantèlement
du sénat seront transformés en créances
sur l'état
je crois qu'un certain d'entre nous ne
serons pas une et très hot de la valeur
d'une créance sur l'état sur un sujet de
ce genre et nous avons vu historiquement
un certain nombre d'épisodes où le
financement par exemple du démantèlement
de l'installation nucléaire a été un
grand péril faute de financement parce
que c'est un financement qui devait être
assurée directement par l'état
et ça se fait qu'il nous fait peur
démantèlement est un sujet important un
sujet de long terme
et quand on commence un démantèlement il
faut être sûr de pouvoir le mener
jusqu'à son terme
si on commence à émietter le
démantèlement en épisodes correspondant
au moment où ses finances et il est
clair qu'on se met dans une situation un
très inefficace et deuxièmement
pendables voilà ce que j'avais en tête
mais encore une fois l'épisode actions
de rte me paraît moins grave que les
pilotes créances sur l'état mais toute
façon c'est une façon de contourner
l'esprit de la loi
oui mais c'est vraiment vous avez vous
même participé participer au vote la loi
et j étais en tant que que fonctionnaire
s'était pas du tout l'esprit doit
laisser la loi c'était des actifs en
tant que tel et avec josiane fait
qu'elle troisième catégorie deux choses
qui sont des créances croisé entre
exploitants nucléaires que dès qu'ils
sont actuellement admise comme
provisions ce qui n'est pas du tout là
aussi esprit la loi sur le lait va lui à
sion des dépenses sous les coups que que
les mesures que l'homme en impose et edf
ont représenté je lui ai dit que c'était
une évaluation préliminaire
tout comme toi de nous avons pas encore
pris la décision allait prendre d'essai
d'ici le 30 juin
donc tu peux pas être très précis je
vais simplement le sentiment mais voyez
j'utilise un terme que vous pouvez
qualifier de qualitatif
j'ai le sentiment qu'une évasion de
l'ordre de 10 milliards de francs et et
le bonheur de grandeur mais je ne peux
absolument pas vous garantir que ce sera
pas 8 ou pas du loup look est comme ça
mais l'ordre de grandeur est et est
clairement de à mes yeux le bon puis
dernier mot sur l'europe je sais c'est
que c'est une discussion que nous avions
déjà eu alors d'un épisode précédent
sais pas où je venais monsieur le
président il me semble que les
difficultés du contrôle d'un contrôle
européen en matière sûreté nucléaire qui
tient au fait que les installations
nucléaires sont son objection pas
seulement technique mais politique
si vous avez des pays qui sont contre le
contre le nucléaire vous l'avez des
partis qui sont contre le nucléaire
à ma connaissance je n'avais pas de pays
ou de partis qui sont contre l'industrie
chimique ou l'industrie métallurgique et
ça veut donc dire que dans nombre de cas
le nucléaire est considéré comme quelque
chose
entraînant la nécessité de position
politique pour ou contre est à mes yeux
le nucléaire ressemble beaucoup
d'organismes génétiquement modifiés sme
c'est très frappant il ya un exemple
d'un secteur où il a été pris le parti
de donner du pouvoir d'europe qui
l'autorisation des organismes
génétiquement modifiés
donc peu de sel peut autoriser des
semences c'est fascinant de voir comment
ça se passe et c'est fascinant de voir
combien dès qu'un pays considère que la
décision de bruxelles ne lui plaît pas
il s'attache à prendre des mesures
réglementaires pour soyons poli
contourner le soyons là aussi plus rudes
heurté la disposition de ses doigts et
mon sentiment c'est que sur des objets
comme les centaines clair ou bien je
viens de pourra tout à fait trouvé une
situation de ce genre
un pays considérant que faire tourner
une centrale nucléaire au contenu à
faire tourner peut tout à fait
justifiées qui n'obéissent pas du tout l
enjeu qui ont supposé bruxelles c'est ça
que j'ai en tête mais alors ça n'empêche
pas du tout qu'il faille dans l'état
actuel des choses essayait de
s'harmoniser autant que possible essayer
d'être aussi cohérente possible alors
une des façons de faire a été après la
décision du conseil européen que le
cahier des charges qui était appliqué
aux autres espèces 12 des versions
complètement sûreté tagai charges
uniques qui a été élaboré par une
association de chefs d'autorité when he
a été approuvé par même serait gay la
commission donc il ya un cahier des
charges unique
il ya des rapports nationaux en leur
majorité ils ont été faites de façon
tout à fait sérieuse et il ya un
processus de revue par les pairs de peer
review qui est actuellement en cours il
ya dix sept rapports nationaux
il ya quinze rapports de pays de l'union
européenne ya un rapport la suisse y un
apport de l'ukraine se fait dix sept
rapports ils sont soumis une produit par
les pairs cette revue par les pairs
mobilisent pour 1 200 experts et est
menée par un des commissaires d'autorité
sur tille car française qui s'appelle
philippe jamet
donc l'un des commissaires et qui a été
directeur de la sûreté nucléaire à lier
donc qui est féru en matière
internationale et cette revue par les
pairs prend les dix sept rapports
nationaux découpe en tranches
le sujet des régions naturelles le sujet
des pères de fonctions pureté de
sujétion crise se trouve aberrant
comporte une visite dans chaque pays une
ville centrale et doit aboutir un
rapport du port de stress tests par don
de parler franglais qui est en cours
d'élaboration et qui devait être
présentée à l'esn trade commission pour
créer par la commission le 25 avril et
qui doit servir de base au rapport que
la commission va donner au conseil
européen
il ya donc un processus d'harmonisation
tout à fait clair je doute que ce
processus a pour but de parvenir si
possible quelques recommandations
quatre ou cinq idées qui sur lesquels le
conseil européen peut tout à fait dire
aux différents pays coûté creuser plus
avant l'application de ces quatre ou
cinq idées principales en tel ou tel
pays nous nous sommes par exemple très
porteurs de l'intérêt du concept noyau
dur je sais pas ce est repris mais c'est
typiquement quelque chose qui serait
intéressant que chaque pays essaie
d'appliquer d'appliquer chez lui donc la
peau de l'obligation qui n'est pas
extrême soit c'est du parc c'est du cas
par cas mais je crois que ça va ça va
dans le bon sens merci monsieur
président du conseil voyez le
c'est la partie de l'installation qui
est davantage protéger contre les
agressions dire typiquement centre de
crise bancarisés et le diesel de
l'ultime secoue plus sa forme d'autres
choses
c'est votre premier rôle laurence
rossignol monsieur le président merci
d'abord de votre propos et je voulais
vous poser quelques questions à question
la première choisir si vous partagez un
propos qu'on a entendu ici qui en fait
consistera à dire qu' il n'y aurait pas
de durée de fonctionnement a priori pour
un équilibre univers réaction nucléaire
que c'est aux contrôles décennale qu'on
peut dire si cet équipement repart pour
dix ans et c'est la fois suivante qu'on
vérifiera si tu peux faire encore dix
ans et qu'en fin de compte n'a pas d'à
priori ce propos la s'appuie sur
l'exemple américain je crois qui est
dans un prolongement assez long est ce
que vous partagez cette analyse ça c'est
ma première question ma deuxième
question c'est concernant le bilan que
vous faites de votre rôle de votre
institution
est-ce que vous paraît possible de
garantir dans d'autres pays à la fois un
nucléaire sûre et une absence autorité
de sûreté indépendante
est ce que dans les pays qui refusent
une autorisation indépendante
on peut penser que le nucléaire pourrait
néanmoins être sûr engendre jusqu aux
adducteurs sur la corée du sud
mais je crois que la question s'est
posée à plusieurs reprises baraka votre
sentiment là-dessus la troisième
question concerne l'étendue de vos de
vos contrôles est-ce que vous contrôlez
les installations s'agit pour y est ce
que vous vous évaluez aussi les
questions de compétence des personnels
affectés au fonctionnement des réacteurs
était question de sous traitance est ce
que ça rentre aussi dans le champ de
votre de votre
pouvoir de contrôle et enfin dernière
question vous faites un rapport annuel
qui est un rapport annuel je crois qui
est essentiellement sur base déclarative
non il ya dans chaque année les
touristes sur nucléaire publie un
récapitulatif
et c'est sur base déclarative de la part
de l'opérateur ça suppose fonctionnement
de confiance c'est ça que vous avez dit
je suis président merci monsieur pesant
d'or tu es sur la durée de
fonctionnement je je je redis que dans
l'état actuel du droit français
l'autorisation de création d'une
installation est donné sans indication
de limites quantitatives dans le temps
la station peut fonctionner aussi
longtemps qu'elle est considérée comme
sûre et nous nous elle sait nous
vérifions cali sur d'une part pas jours
à jour par des inspections comme x 1000
milles par an par là dedans des
inspections réactive après incident et
puis pas rendez vous plus solennelle
tous les dix ans c'est la façon de faire
française c'est généralement la façon de
faire européenne
ce n'est pas de façon de faire
américaine et nous attachons essayer de
convertir les américains à l'idée qu'une
révision périodique fureter tron appelle
ps et en anglais public safety review
est une bonne chose
nous avons beaucoup de mal un mot là
aussi sur le japon le japon ne
pratiquait pas les public safety review
tous les dix ans et tout laisse penser
que le réacteur general electric les
recteurs général et rick fukushima
n'avait guère bougé depuis l'origine je
pense qu'en france directeur ce genre
aurait été mis au goût du jour autant
qu'il était possible tout au moins tous
les dix ans deuxième chose sur le
problème de l'indépendance de l'autorité
de sûreté l'indépendance d'autorité
sûreté est quelque chose qui ce qui se
construit qui se conquiert au cours du
temps c'est pour l'auto était française
entre sa création en 1973 et la loi tsn
qui a été voté par l'immense majorité
des partis en 2006 il s'est écoulé 33
ans est tout à fait clair que notre
indépendance accrue au cours du temps
d'abord cru de fait de facto n'ai pas
beaucoup souvenir d'avoir reçu beaucoup
d'ordres de ministre quand nous
dépendons ministre et puis elle est
devenue des jurés par la loi tsn ça se
construit pas à pas quand je visite un
santon notre pays tu as est frappée de
voir qu'ils sont dans un état
intermédiaire il ya des pays où
l'autorité sûreté peine encore à sortir
de l'équivalent du ceva ya des pays où
l'autorité davantage évolué puis elle
est payée qui paraissent matures comme
comme c'est le cas par exemple ou aux
états-unis au canada mais c'est résultat
d'un long processus est un processus qui
n'est pas simple parce que dans beaucoup
de pays pouvoir politique considère et
qui n'est pas normal de délégués à une
autorité indépendante d'un pouvoir
régalien ce gîte de ce type
je vous rappelle qu'en 1999 le conseil
d'état a indiqué sue en projet de loi
crée en auto et tm sera ivan est
vraiment le conseil et a indiqué au
premier ministre lionel jospin qui
n'était pas bien de songer à créer une
autorité en sera-t-il indépendante sur
un domaine aussi fondamentale la sûreté
nucléaire et premier mini de l'époque a
jugé qu'il ne pouvait pas passer outre
qui fait que la loi n'a été votée qu'en
2006 donc c'est un sujet sensible et
politiquement sensible je pense qu'une
évolution en ce sens la corée du sud
vient craint
une autorité qui a vocation à être
indépendante le japon va essayer
d'améliorer la situation
c'est très difficile très très difficile
votre question suivante porte sur le
point de savoir si nous contrôlons les
compétences à tous traitance oui soit
nous sommes extrêmement porteur du fait
que la sûreté nucléaire s'est pas
uniquement loin de là des questions
mécanique de béton de construction mais
que c'est fondamentalement une
compétence humaine qu'est ce que j'avais
d'évoquer tout à leur facteur humain
socio organisationnel et nous sommes
porteurs d'une chose qui est tout à fait
fondamental se fait jamais une
utilisation de mots erreur humaine
auparavant toujours de facteurs sociaux
additionnels une mère parce que je ne
connais aucune personne indiquée pour
volonté de faire des erreurs
très souvent ces personnes fait d'erreur
ce qui a été mal formés vous pouvez dans
mauvaises conditions de travail
c'est fondamental j'ajoute que nous
sommes extrêmement porteur aussi du fait
que quand une erreur a été commise punir
la personne n'est pas la chose à faire
vous essayez de comprendre pourquoi ça
s'est fait c'est un des sujets que l'on
abordé de nouveau dans le groupe de
travail facteurs sociaux opérationnel
humain que nous allons convoquer
prochainement dans le cadre des suites
de fukushima dernier élément vous avez
évoqué un rapport annuel sur base
déclarative que je n'ai pas bien saisi
ce que vous évoquez
nous publions chaque année un rapport
annuel mais qui est le nôtre
les réponses à vos questions à vos
interrogations de l'exploitant sont des
réponses déclaratif c'est ça que vous le
dire je crois non son signal nous
considérons que l'exploitant à 100 euros
c'est vrai qu'en quand comme comme nous
l'imposent ont quelque chose est patent
il doit le faire quand nous posons des
quatre exploitants il doit répondre mais
à l'évidence c'est sa responsabilité
puis à nous de voir ce que nous faisons
de sa réponse je je je je prends un
exemple c'est vrai que nous publions
tout modèle nous faisons mais
l'inflexion nous publions nos miled de
suite
l'exploitant ne répond nous publions
palette de l'exploitant sur notre site
parce que nous concédons la
responsabilité des exploitants
mais nous prenons ensuite les décisions
qui nous paraissait adéquat merci
monsieur président ronan dantec qui ne
va pas faire un exposé mais qui va poser
des questions je ne fais jamais
d'exposer je pose des questions précises
parfois plusieurs ce qui va être le cas
première question concerne ans ce
prolongement des centres ad j'ai bien
noté votre mot surfer quand on a un
souci important si jamais demain on
était en situation de conflit entre
sécurité dégradé et fourniture
d'électricité edf nous annonce
aujourd'hui un investissement d'environ
50 milliards pour prolonger le parc
actuel de 40 à 60 ans donc on a bien
compris que votre niveau
tous les dix ans vous redonner une
autorisation pour dix ans mais je
n'imagine pas mais vous allez me
préciser les choses qui n'est pas
d'aller retour entre l'exploitant et
vous sur les investissements nécessaires
pour obtenir ce ce prolongement de 20
ans en terme de sécurité donc j'aimerais
que vous nous expliquer mieux où on vous
en êtes de ce dialogue un peu comme sur
les 10 milliards de f vous a fourni un
document disant voilà comment les 10
milliards on sécurité pourrait se
dispatcher et nous serions d'ailleurs
tout à fait intéressé pourra voir le
document dans lequel edf
on n'a pas droit même en commission
denquête tout cas si nous pouvons avoir
le document
si c'est dans les prérogatives de la
commission denquête nous en serions
ravis donc première question c'est
autour de ces 50 milliards parce que on
imagine pas qu edf investit 50 milliards
avec vous derrière vous dit
allez vous faire mais quand même donc
voilà comment commence cela se passe à
ce niveau la première question
deuxième question concernant le mox qui
est en question importante en termes de
sécurité
on dit mais peut-être que vous allez me
démentir que en termes de bombardements
des des cuves le mox est potentiellement
plus plus agressif sur la sur la cub et
pourrait aussi amener à une réaction
accéléré or comme une force d'action
rapide qui n'est quand même quelques
heures à intervenir plus le plus la
vitesse en cas de perte de contrôle est
grande plus le risque d'une perte de
contrôle définitive et très grandes
banques est ce que le la filière mox en
termes de sécurité est un choix
raisonnable et notamment dans une
logique de de prolongement des centrales
actuelles
troisième question c'est une
interrogation par rapport à fukushima on
a quand même eu beaucoup de soucis sur
les piscines
on parle toujours du coeur en activité
et on oublie souvent les piscines
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas proposer un
confinement des piscines suite à
fukushima
donc là je parle maintenant de fukushima
et pas uniquement du prolongement en vie
normale et puis c'est malheureusement
une une actualité toujours barbare un
avion détourné qui tombe sur une piscine
ça fait quand même beaucoup de dégâts
donc on aimerait savoir comment vous
voyez ce cas de figure très très précis
pourquoi on n'allait pas arriver à la
conclusion du confinement des piscines
et dernière question très courte
où en est-on sûr le père puisque vous
suivez attentivement ce dossier du
contrôle commande où on nous dit qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup de difficultés
sur le contrôle-commande et plus
généralement
donc on a bien vu qu'il y avait sur la
main sur le gros oeuvre un certain
nombre de difficultés
est ce que demain on a encore à votre
avis
beaucoup de difficultés à venir mais
plus las sur la gestion du coeur du
système lui même
bravo monsieur d'entraygues pour la
brièveté monsieur le président
sa première question porte sur l'ailé et
50 milliards annoncés par par edf et
l'algérie c'est vraiment responsabilité
d'edf
je ne sais pas ce que causé 50 milliards
qui sont teintées hâtivement annoncé
comme destinée à prolonger la durée de
fonctionnement des réacteurs au-delà de
30 ans comme destiné à passer de 40 à 60
ans je ne sais pas ce que sont ces cinq
ans tenir par ailleurs nous avons entamé
un dialogue et edf sur la possibilité de
prolonger la durée de fonctionnement de
40 à 60 ans quand une fois c'est le
début d'un dialogue mais on dit edf
il faudra vérifier la conformité vos
matériels essentiellement les cuves et
le confinement et puis par ailleurs nous
vous poserons la question des pâtes
progrès que vous pouvez faire pour
rapprocher les objectifs sûreté des
réacteurs existants du recteur européen
on est au début du dialogue comme ma
connaissance nous n'avons enfin de nous
aucun aucune évaluation quelle qu'elle
soit sur le mox lui-même soit je pense
pas que l'utilisation du mox et la
moindre conséquence sur les conditions
d'intervention de la force d'action
rapide pourra peut-être en parler plus
en détail si vous voulez je n'ai pas du
tout l'impression que ce soit le cas sur
les fukushima
les cube ont beau bar de nuit sur des
lits sur le prolongement du parc non sur
la cuve ya pas de conséquences
non je sais tu que si quelque chose
seulement douzième degré n'en ont pas du
tout leflux d'états d'âme on pourra en
parler plus en détail sur fukushima et
les piscines et tout s'éclaire savait
que les piscines de combustible usé sont
en dessous si certains n'ont pas
laquelle d'ailleurs j'ai dit l'air nous
l'avons étendue en france le champ des
stress tests au hasard dont d'autres
invitations dont dont la passion dotées
de piscines et là le problème s'est posé
savoir pour nous s'il si une piste de
confinement était à privilégier nous
avons regardé nous en avons discuté avec
l'opérateur en l'état que les choses ça
nous paraît pas la piste à privilégier
et nous préférons privilégier la piste
consistant à prévenir autant qu'il est
possible les risques de
perte de refroidissement cas de perte de
perte de 1
mais là aussi si vous voulez on pourra
en discuter et la position que nous
prenons la conforme à celle que prennent
la plupart de nos collègues que vous
donnez la question porte sur le contrôle
commande de p r nous allons publier sous
quelques jours
notre position sur le contrôle commande
de ppr qui consisterait à dire que nous
considérons que les réserves que nous
l'avons posée en octobre 2009 en octobre
2009 sont levés une lettre va essayer d
ici quelques jours et une note
d'information va être diffusé j'ajoute
que ceux ci aient consécutive un certain
nombre de contacts avec nos homologues
qui sont en charge du contrôle de la
construction de père en chine en
finlande est possible possiblement
cependant est de toutes façons possibles
ou au royaume uni mais ces messieurs
président en m'excusant premier riechers
puisqu'il avait posé la question avant
jean claude lenoir
bien merci président revenant très
rapidement sur le rôle de l'asn je vais
vous dire ici monsieur lacoste que la
façon dont l'asn exerce son autorité et
une véritable assurance qui est apportée
à ce qu'ils croient nucléaire il n'y a
pas d'autorité sûreté nucléaire au monde
qui est l'autorité vous avez je le dis
car c'est souvent une façon de répondre
à ceux qui très légitimement d'ailleurs
pose des questions sur la fiabilité du
nucléaire une chose est sûre c'est que
le nucléaire n'est pas entre les mains
des politiques même si bleu vais
soulever un problème qui n'est pas sans
sans nous interroger
c'est vraiment une autorité qui s'est
affirmé depuis 2006 alors renom très
rapidement sur des questions assez
mineures je reste vous le savoir comment
sont déclenchées les et contrôle
lorsqu'il ya l'incident les entrants
nucléaire c'est une déclaration de
l'opérateur qui en fuite vous fait
intervenir lorsqu'il y a des
communications de la part de l'opérateur
10 ans il ya eu un incident niveau 1
niveau 2 en fait c'est après que vous
l'ayez vous même vérifier comment ça se
passe lorsqu'un incident se produit
deuxièmement ces conseils les actifs
vertueux je crains un peu troublé parce
que j'ai le sentiment que vous raisonner
par rapport la lys à sion qui était
précédente à celle de 2006 concernant la
structure d'edf dire que les au moment
où situez vous semble ignorer que
ensuite les réseaux de notamment de
transport sont devenus filiale à 100%
d'edf
vous avez le sentiment en déclarant ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure que ce
sont des planètes un peu éloigné d'edf
bon simplement avoir votre réponse aux
sur ce point lors concernant le p r
j'aurais souhaité vérifier auprès de
vous que vous avez des contacts avec
olkiluoto en finlande et taishan en
chine qui sont donc les deux autres de
ppr qui s'en aille ou en construction à
ce qu'il y ait une coopération
internationale sur la façon dont on
construit les recteurs du type père en
disant différents pays et même comment
les choses peuvent se passer dans des
dans les années qui viennent pour qui
les comparaisons de fait la semaine
dernière nous avons entendu une personne
qui a une certaine autorité sur ces
questions monsieur champsaur
nous nous affirmait que nous étions en
situation de surcapacité upr que la
question d'augmenter les capacités d'ici
à 15 ans ne se posait pas alors c'est
pas votre rôle d'un évaluer les besoins
de la france en termes de capacité de
production d'origine nucléaire il
parlait bien d'origine nucléaire
néanmoins on ne peut pas déconnecter
complètement votre rôle de
l'appréciation qui est fait notamment
lorsque vous avez soulevé la question
très pertinente du conflit entre un
problème qui s'opposent sur un réacteur
et les problèmes d'approvisionnement
bon ça veut bien dire qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas dans le cas de la scène
ignoré la question de la capacité
production et donc des besoins en
électricité
enfin dernière question est ce que vous
avez j'ai pas non c'est avant qu'il ya
une van lent c'est très court quel est
votre avis sur fessenheim c'est à dire
sur les précautions à prendre par
rapport au sous sol c'est est-ce que
vous avez j'imagine qu'un avis donc ils
mentent simplement votre avis
sais pas quand je vais reprendre la
question dans l'ordre le premier pas je
suis sensible aux louanges exprimé par
monsieur noir sur de l'asn simplement le
rapporteur est bien notée te dire que je
dise éjecté d'un confortable création de
le sujet et et je vous prie de croire
que compte tenu des responsabilités qui
sont les nôtres nous ne sommes pas bardé
de certitudes tranquilles une autorité
de sûreté qui commence à croire qu'elle
est bonne et sûrement en train devenir
mauvaise tout à fait fondamentale et
c'est vraiment le type des changes que
nous avons avec nos homologues
nous échangeons plutôt des telle
interrogation et la nécessité de
travailler que qu'autre chose je le
deuxième point que soulevait par
monsieur noah les déclarations incident
déclaration incidents sont dus
obligatoire par là par la loi nous y
veillons quand l'incident le mérite nous
faisons une inspection et nous les
d'élite ont pas à sanctionner quand ce
n'est pas le cas - exemple sur la tp ou
d'ateliers traitement du plutonium à
cadarache
le ceva d'éclat avec beaucoup de retard
en insistant que tu es un incident
sérieux
nous avons dressé pv nous avons envoyé
le sait au tribunal et le ser vient
d'être condamné par le tribunal à
marseille nous ne payerons ne présentons
pas avec la nécessité de déclaré
l'incident en temps utile ce qui est
fondamental c'est la base du retour
d'expérience c'est la base de
l'amélioration sabah la sûreté sur les
titres rte et étaient est un exemple des
points qui ont été relevé par noé qui
ont été relayés par la cour c'est à dire
on est en train pampa de s'éloigner de
l'esprit de la loi et internationaux par
l'exemple le plus criant
mais tu es quand on voit que les charges
futures du cerf sont couvertes par des
titres d'areva et par des créances sur
l'état on est aux antipodes de ce que
vous des lois mais je n'ai pas de la
cepal c'est pas mon domaine strict de
compétences mais nous partageons ce
shôjo souci par peur qu'un beau jour on
soit incapable de financer l'ensemble
l'opération
de démantèlement et le traitement des
déchets vous avez envie de porter le
problème de la du partage
internationales en matière de sûreté du
réacteur p r ça se fait via un club qui
a été fondée par une dizaine d'autorités
de sûreté qui s'appelle m2p
multinationales des line d'évaluation
programme qui a été fondée en fait par
l'autorité américaine et l'autorité
française via les goûts de travail
thématiques sur suire contrôle commande
sur l' inspection api rivaux de travail
par type de réacteur et en parking coûte
le travail sur les acteurs repères et
c'est là que nous discutons avec nos
collègues américains chinois
britanniques finlandais et canadiens
d'un certain nombre de sujets de ppr sur
le contrôle commande chez soi dans
groupe ppr soit dans le groupe contrôle
commande mais que c'est là que nous
avons échangé pour aboutir à la
conclusion que j'ai indiqué en réponse à
votre question
ça marche les différents d'autorité
apporte plus de moins prennent plus ou
moins mais ça marche sur phénomène de
surcapacités nucléaire
nous n'avons pas vocation à nous ne
sommes pas équipés pour porter un
jugement de leurs capacités ou
surcapacité chronique et sûrement
d'autres shows 6 mhz il faut éviter de
nous trouver un phénomène de sous
capacités ou de capacité limite
entraînant un conflit extrêmement
difficile à traiter entre sécurité et
approvisionnement et puis dernier point
sur fessenheim souhaite surfer normal
notre position n'a n'a pas évolué ces
dernières semaines nous avons pris
position sur fait 100 m 2 x ont pris
position sur fessenheim 1 au terme de la
troisième révision décennale émis des
propositions juillet 2011
et là nous avons des eaux terme cette
révision nous l'impôt long de mémoire
une trentaine de prescription quand une
quarantaine de prescription les deux
principales étant épaississement du
radier n'aura dit fessenheim été
nettement plus ou moins épais que lui
les autres centrales pour deux raisons
historiques et puis deuxièmement mise en
place a fait sa noble une source
alternative de refroidissement
des siens super source principale c'est
ça qu'on a imposé en juillet sur ces
deux mesures là on avait dit à
fessenheim 1 vous nous présenter un
dossier pour la fin d'année le dossier a
été présenté
nous sommes en train de l'examiner la
première fois qu'on a regardé fixement
et puis on a regardé fessenheim outils
de la procédure fukushima donc la
première fukushima on a imposé un
ensemble de choses nouvelles comme le
noyau dur des là l'ultime secours sans
de gestion de crise bunkeriser comme
force d'action rapide ça s'applique à
toute centrale de fessenheim toumi les
mesures spécifiques afin qu à fessenheim
demeure applicable à fessenheim et s'y
rajoutent les mesures générales
applicables à tous il s'empale d'edf
monsieur le président mes recherches
si monsieur brésil
la première vous avez parlé à l'instant
de cadarache donc à une déclaration qui
se fait vous d'un incident et moi ce que
je souhaiterais savoir c'est justement
suite à un incident de la même façon
fessenheim vous dites qu'il ya des
préconisations quelle force vous avez
pour que vos préconisations se
transforme en réalisation c'est à dire
'est-ce que vous suivez ce qui a suivi
est ce qu'il ya des délais j'avoue que
je ne sais pas comment vous fonctionnez
pour après l'incident
ma deuxième question est est ce qu'à
votre avis monsieur le président
n'est-il pas temps d'apprendre à des
construire une centrale nucléaire
je dis ça très tranquillement en dehors
de toute polémique c'est à dire bientôt
beaucoup de nos centrales vont arriver
presque à terme de leur temps de
fonctionnement raisonnable et afin qu'on
ne soit pas pris par le temps j'ai envie
de demander de vous demander votre
sentiment sur une déconstruction
tranquille qui nous qui ferait écoles et
qui serait utile pour la suite
ma troisième question l'asn avait émis
un avis en effet le 3 janvier 2012 en
disant que vous estimiez que le facteur
humain était l'un des piliers de sûreté
nucléaire de la sûreté dans les
centrales
or il y a plus de 30000 salariés de
sous-traitants
vous dites que vous connaissez ou que
vous surveillez bien sûr leurs
compétences
ne serait-il pas temps là aussi davos
afin d'avoir des préconisations pour
limiter la sous traitance de façon assez
drastiques notamment dans les dents le
coeur enfin dans le coeur du métier
nucléaire j'ai envie de dire par
périphérique
il semble que ces derniers temps mais je
suis honteux pas aussi mais informer que
vous bien sûr les inflations de la sous
traitance peut-être à terme dangereuse à
la fois pour six salariés mais aussi
pour les fonctionnement des centrales
est la dernière question porte
de la même façon sur les les
les composants par exemple je sais pas
sous votre couvert mais il me semble que
les composants de la turbine de le père
de flamanville de flamanville sont
fabriqués dans 11 pays différents
peut-être pourquoi ne serait-il pas
fabriqué en france pour une meilleure
sûreté justement un meilleur contrôle de
ses pièces n'est-il pas bon non plus
d'avoir une préconisation forte de faire
en sorte que ces pièces puissent être
fabriqués en france et a semblé aussi
ici en france comme elles le sont merci
mes recherches monsieur président est
preneur
première chose c'est ça la question
porte sur les préconisations dans
préconisation est un mot inconnu chez
nous nous prenons des décisions et qui
sont des décisions comminatoire
applicable et et dont nous vérifions
l'application avec avec des délais si je
prends l'exemple de la tp eu comme nous
l'avons appris cette non déclaration
d'un incident nous avons suspendu le
fonctionnement de la tp eu enfin
suspendu le démantèlement bud des
différentes cellules atpu nous les avons
avons soumis à d'autres choses que à
notre autorisation de redémarrage donc
nous devons surveiller d'extrêmement
près les choses en vérifiant que c'est
l'installation était remise en l'état
sur et que le plutonium un excédent
était correctement traités encore une
fois nous fonctionnons autorités c'est
pas un assez bon cela nous prenons des
sillons sont pas de préconisations
décrétant on n'a pas le choix
sur le deuxième paquet à des
constructions
c'est en france nous n'avons pas
l'habitude de déconstruire des
installations des centrales nucléaires
il ya déjà eu des de la décontraction
d'autres natation nucléaire le centre de
fontenay
2 tu seras est en cours de démantèlement
le démantèlement du centre du cea de
grenoble est pratiquement achevée donc
il ya des expériences de déconstruction
mais nous poussons autant que possible
pour avoir des glands de déconstruction
en vraie grandeur de centrales c'est
pour ça que nous avions poussé edf a
démenti aussi vite que possible
brennilis
après nice a connu un certain nombre
d'aléas en particulier juridique
c'est pour ça que nous poussons les
démantèlements aussi vite que possible
la centrale de choses
ah c'est pour ça que nous poussons aussi
vite que possible démantèlement des
réacteurs le fuyait rue adjugée pour
avoir d'expérience alors vous direz
c'est l'expérience porte que des types
de réacteurs qui correspond pas à la
fille actuelle mais au moins ils
permettent de rassembler expérience et
de faire la comparaison avec des pays
étrangers
mais pour nous il est tout à fait
fondamental de sortir des oiseaux
théorique pour avoir les évaluations en
vraie grandeur
donc on peut ce président mireille nous
sommes allés voir la déconstruction de
brennilis en bretagne vendredi prochain
notre à porter va voir show la
déconstruction de choses
ah si jamais votre emploi du temps vous
permet allez-y ça vaut la peine c'est
intéressant parce que ce sont les deux
centrales qui soit déjà un niveau 50 %
de déconstruction
alors sur le troisième point sur les
facteurs sociaux initialement c'est une
partageant tout à fait le sentiment que
c'est tout à fait fondamental est que
quand on parle uniquement des composants
d'une installation
on oublie que cette installation est
gérée et opéré par par des gens alors
cruellement en ordre de grandeur il ya
vingt mille personnes d'edf qui
travaillent centrallia va me sous
traitants c'est l'ordre de grandeur
les conditions de travail des sous
traitants sont un de nos soucis alors
c'est un chantier qu'on va ouvrir
on l'annoncé d'ici l'été avec la
participation de l'ensemble des parties
prenantes et syndicats
j'ai eu que d'ores et déjà devant après
une disposition dans un arrêté sur
l'installation car de base ce qui a été
signé le 9 février directement
consécutif à fukushima qui est obligé
edf sur la surveillance directe des
l'opération sous traiter quand elle
touche à d'éléments importants pour la
sûreté
mais ce n'est que le premier élément de
l'ensemble de ce que nous vous
souhaitons déroulé enfin la turbine la
turbine qui est pas chez nous c'est un
équipement classique il peut y avoir
multitude sous traitants que je peux
vous garantir c'est que quand il s'agit
d'un dossier touchant tout nucléaire
nous regardons de très près et en
particulier quand pyatt sous traitance à
l'étranger nous allons vérifier sur
place qui se passe j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure c'est que à l'occasion de la
fabrication à son devis rôle d'un
pressuriseur par un sous traitant
italien de la firme en groupe nous
avions arrêté la fabrication il a bien
obligé areva a déclassé une partie des
fournitures dont on surveille de très
près je devrais le savoir c'est une
turbine alstom non je devrais le savoir
soit turbines alstom pour flamanville
non mais je devrais sans doute de savoir
aussi mais je ne sais pas merci monsieur
président pu écouter joue merci vraiment
pour la précision de toutes vos réponses
nous avons beaucoup apprécié et je suis
sûr que votre audition fera poids
et autorité dans notre le futur rapport
que notre reporter rédigera et je vous
en remercie infiniment me permettez vous
de dire monsieur présent que vraiment
très profondément
l'asn est à disposition du parlement
quel que soit le sujet traité quelle que
soit la forme plus ou moins solennelle
des conditions dans lesquelles ils à
l'instigation est menée j'ai beaucoup
apprécié votre introduction et le
président de groupe énergie que je suis
par ailleurs abusera peut-être de sa à
la rentrée parlementaire c'est-à-dire à
l'automne prochain
merci beaucoup
voilà pour cette audition d'andré claude
lacoste le président de l'asn autorité
de sûreté nucléaire si vous souhaitez la
revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
à suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction preuve par 3 qui reçoit ce
soir nathalie arthaud candidate de lutte
ouvrière à l'élection présidentielle
très belle soirée à tous